i went to a blockbuster
video
this is about maybe
maybe a month ago
i went and visited my ex-girlfriend she
lives in bend oregon
if you believe in that place
i went and visited her and uh
and
they had a blockbuster
video up there the last one
and i couldn't believe it right when i
got there some guy was dropping the
videos off in the door in the outdoor
slot
some dude that i mean i can't the
overdue finds he must have had steep
sprack
um
those overdue fines were upstairs baby
them [ __ ] was upstairs
uh
and
yeah and then you go in and it's just a
flood of the past
it's like that yellow that was kind of
the yellow was a little bit stolen by
the minions kind of
they kind of took that blockbuster
yellow
and it was just like the wooden like uh
the kind of
prefab kind of
wooden uh
there was like you know what i'm talking
about the wood the paneling type of wood
you know it wasn't paneling it was like
these like
it was like kind of plywood i think but
it had like this like laminate over it
and
and you just saw the movie you saw the
thing dramas telev uh
television was a section and it was just
on
dvd or c i don't even know what the what
format it was on in there
but it was awesome you just
and you saw so many titles that was the
thing
you saw all the titles like oh what is
this one
you know
russian uh
you know bomber or something
oh russian bomber i've never seen this
and you read it
you know like somebody bombs a russian
that was like the synopsis to me like
this [ __ ] sounds
pretty bad you know
my stepdad would like it that's one of
those movies you know
like jack reacher 70 he would like that
um
but yeah one thing that was interesting
you got to see all the movie with the
different sections kids adults
uh
teens and they had drama violence
horror you go to the little section like
oh well look at all these movies you
know
uh rambo you know rambo uh
like a
rambo
remember that
or they'd have like bad attack and like
two you know dangerous bats attack a
family or something and you know outside
of des moines though
and they're like damn they [ __ ] these
bats are getting people damn these bats
um
but the one thing interesting thing i
thought about being at the blockbuster
was you got to uh
you made a choice you had all the things
and you made a choice
you went and you were like oh
this one looks pretty good i'll make
this choi i'm gonna chew
there was just so many choi you could
wander and you could choose like
felt like you had so many
options and you got to make a choice
whereas with the streaming platforms now
you turn it on the most you can see on a
screen at one time is about eight or ten
names
and i don't really and it feels like
it's the same you could go through every
section and they give you the same you
know nine options
you're like damn
so that was one thing that felt
interesting at the blockbuster was that
i got to make the choice i
you know maybe i'd be in comedy section
i'd be looking to see you know let me
look over there
you know they got horror films or they
got a geriatric um
you know nightmare or whatever pudding
nightmares or whatever
and you go over there and look at that
they got construction you know different
[ __ ]
in one area it's just blueprints rolled
up you could read them [ __ ]
you know bad blueprints a lot of stuff
from probably like uh
areas where there's like a high water
table you're like damn
so if you know about blueprints some of
that [ __ ] can be very very scary
uh
but i just thought it was interesting
you got to me i felt so much more like i
made the choice at blockbuster
whereas with the streamer platforms i
feel like the choice is kind of made for
you they're making the choice in the
background
you know they're giving you these here's
12 options choose this is you know
but it blocked but it just felt like
here's all the options
and maybe because at blockbuster you're
physically moving so you're kind of
wandering through the ah there's a more
of like you doing
an action to go choose something
i don't know it was definitely i i just
felt strongly like man i miss having the
choice
as opposed to what it feels like now
more is that it gets
it kind of gets chosen for you you don't
it doesn't really
but the screen is just you know it's
just such a small screen that they
they're gonna they hit you with it
enough you might click on it
but yeah it was crazy the new releases
and the pete the workers are up there
and they're like doing the little thing
where they take the thing off and make
sure nobody's stealing and [ __ ] god
it was such a throwback
and then they had the little candies
they had the um
there was always a couple of packs they
had nestles then they had the nestle
nugget bites or whatever
the butterfinger bites when them [ __ ]
came out dude
we i had a buddy broke into a [ __ ]
blockbuster and got six packs of those
bites
got six packs of those bites dude
of uh
butterfinger bites bro
damn dude
you'd have something to do if your step
dad had two things of freaking bites
you'd [ __ ] wake his ass up get the
[ __ ] up stanley get up darren
get up [ __ ]
i want them bites dog i want them bites
when them [ __ ] hit the scene bro when
bites hit the scene
when butterfinger bites hit the scene
bro when nestle bites
yeah damn dog
you'd see people in their [ __ ]
backyards training their bulldog to go
get one get that [ __ ]
get that [ __ ] reginald get that [ __ ]
get that [ __ ] boy get that bite
it's a different time man [ __ ]
was amped
and then they had the other candy it was
like the last i was like the package
just looks like kind of tropical colors
like red and yellow and or
blue
like what is that you know
oh
yeah so that was it man that was it
but it was just yeah and the p oh i took
a picture of the people working in there
and they got upset they said you can't
take pictures of the humans in there
and they had a little spot at the back
of the block bus you do a birthday in
there if you want get your friends over
there
you know if you still got enough friends
it'll come to a birthday that remember
blockbuster that's a little [ __ ]
that's diced out and also with
blockbuster you drove over there
you had to get your mom to bring you
over there she'd be out there smoking in
a car
she'd be out there smoking and yell
something get something good
and you'd be in that [ __ ] and a lot of
times she gave you money to get a movie
and you got a game that was a crazy
you brought that [ __ ] back in
mommy like what movie is it you'd be
like oh
oh
double dragon
and then she beat your ass or something
or beat half your ass
a smart mother leave you with half an
ass to sit
on i remember my mother whooped me so
bad one time i had to ride home on all
fours on the back seat
because i just had too much damage on my
ass
too much ass damage
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one